do you think that Joe would ever start a
platform
because obviously having a club is
amazing right it's a it's a tangible
thing where you're right there you can
get up on stage you know it's like this
is the real art yeah but I wonder if he
ever creates like a you know like his
like his own YouTuber like his own
because I feel like he would be the one
obviously you know he has the most
gravitational pull he could and the
thing is I think he already has I think
that he just doesn't want need or want
all the credit you know what I mean it
doesn't need to be called the Rogan
Network he just pushes the things that
he believes in you know what I mean I
think we're all part of that extension I
mean there is no question that he is
that his show is the new Carson it's the
new Tonight Show like getting on it and
being part of that Universe it means
you're going to get bigger
even when they came after him even when
they tried to cancel him he got bigger
everything just gets bigger even I when
all the crazy stuff happened to me and
there's a few days where I'm like oh my
God am I about to go be a crab fisherman
in Alaska like what the [ __ ] am I about
to do and to see that oh my God
everything got a thousand times better
like it's you know
so I think he sort of already has this
universe you know and you know if they
ever really really really come down on
free speech and you know if YouTube gets
crazy or anything like that then you
know there's totally something that's
gonna have to happen
um but I think right now he's he's doing
everything he can for like other people
it's incredible how he you know one
thing that's not often talked about is
you know sometimes you'll go see some of
the biggest comedians on planet Earth
and you'll notice that their opening
acts like aren't always really like
they're not like their own Killers like
you know what I mean like a lot going
back to last night like I'm like I
I wasn't like uh I hope I can't follow
Theo you know what I mean because we
we've always done this dance we've been
growing up before and after one another
for over a decade continuously I and
this comes you know and this is
something that Joe and I have always had
in common is like we Thrive we love the
idea of giving the people the best
possible human crazy ass show and
pulling it off you know it's not
fear-driven uh like I think a lot of
people are because he's not like that
yeah well it's not like Joe Ro or Joey
Diaz the feature for him in an arena in
Atlantic City you know and and all this
chaos and Ari sphere and Duncan and all
these wild people you me all the you
know who wants to really follow that
it's someone that wants to get better
and help people that he thinks are the
best and you know so yeah not having the
fear driven yeah I mean he followed
Chappelle in that arena in Columbus two
weeks ago like butter like it was
nothing and it was you know he doesn't
have that part in if he doesn't have
that fear thing really exactly fear is
not a factor for him it really isn't
that crazy yeah no it really isn't and
if it was you'd never fight I don't
think you could see it he's a diabolical
human being like I mean you know
obviously he has a just like anybody
nowadays there's a ton of haters out
there that can pick apart this like oh
horse paced but like anything you try to
get them on it's easily provable that
right you're just wrong like people that
you know oh he's not a good stand-up
well you're crazy because all of your
favorite stand-ups think he's an
unbelievable stand-up comedian every
single one of your favorite comedians
thinks he's a great comedian knows he's
a great comedian he's been doing it
three decades just because you know him
from a podcaster from my vermec dinner
from CNN it doesn't change what reality
is there's a lot of opinions out there
yeah but someone like him and it's so
rare there's not even there's not even a
second place like he's like
you know as far as helping people and
you know staying humble he's an
incredible inspiration in that way and I
think
yeah it's easy for that to slip away and
once someone thinks that they have it
all figured out I think that's when it
starts to slip and he doesn't do that
he's constantly writing he is he knew
his hour now though when I saw two
months ago man it was it's I mean you
don't want to say it's the best stuff
I've seen him do but that's okay to say
it's the I yeah I think he's done a lot
of really really great stuff it's the
best stuff that I've seen him do and you
do want to say that about people because
you do want them to continue to you know
yeah it's like 20 years in to be doing
the best stuff it's where you're
supposed to be really exactly but man if
[ __ ] that [ __ ] really really floored
me I think there's something about you
know mainstream media going after him
that made him want to be even better and
I'll show you idiots
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one